[Music]
hey I'm in Resaca Georgia I thought I'd
join up with a bunch of Civil War
reenactors today see if I have what it
takes to be a Civil War soldier this is
captain Mike McCann is that correct no
sir good to see you sir kuzmich so
pretty much everything you do all day
long you have to commit to its the Civil
War sir you live in the 1860s feel that
my hands get very dry sometimes so I
brought this no we'll just kind of hear
me out
it's a cream that I get what's nice is
it's grapeseed oil
No so it lubricates me ask you what
you're wearing what is this made of wool
wool can be very unforgiving under here
I actually wear long johns underneath it
I like to go commando pretty much I like
to let things kind of just swing in the
breeze you know I'm saying is that cool
or do I need to wear long johns that's
between you and your pendulum okay it's
a lipstick it's lip balm do you know
what happens to my lips when I don't
moisturize constantly know they get
parched
do you like some by the way no okay one
question I have for you your earring is
that something that Civil War soldier
would have worn something new yeah I
forgot to take it out oh so you just
criticized me for using lip balm
little grape see ya go for your hand
you're dressed like a pirate who's about
to go clubbing so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if the Rebs are out there I know they
are flavors division right over that
hill and I'm not worried
well I admire your confidence serve it
tell me that in about a month if you're
still alive you're not a lot of fun to
talk to falling right when everybody
over here yes sir okay daddy
I don't think I've met everybody I'm
Jedediah long long tree hey boom and
play Fred all right everybody hydrate my
canteen is empty sir ma'am sir
almost got it goodness hydrate take a
rest right now
take a rest sir freakin Rebs are that
way sir I suggest we go fight somebody
everybody need to hydrate you guys seem
to hydrate a lot sir
really done much yet sir I've seen women
in a spin class drink West sir
we must add just coming off sir do you
mind I'd like to work on my character a
bit just ask me questions and we'll
develop my character and then I'll know
who I am okay so ask me like my name
where I'm from stuff like that where are
you from there you're a nosy son of a
[ __ ] my name's Jedediah longtree
I've come from a little farm over yonder
where yonder over yonder I just wanted
to join the army join their army cuz I
hate them too much sir is it okay no
what's wrong okay much about sufferin
don't know much about numbers and such
but I know you do that too much you'll
get as shown you even go - look at you
sorry but I'm really sorry I didn't mean
that's it I'm gonna get back to the
character
[Music]
Huna rib eye laxity and my way live
there they a lot of battles to Iowa
Okefenokee sarsaparilla Creek battle of
all of the garden that been involved now
I don't know much about ciphers and
numbers I don't know what the sky is
never heard of the Sun never saw any
dirt but I'll tell you this my mama
makes the best peach pie you never did I
think about my mom every day I want to
get back to that Creek and I want to see
some of her peach pie
see too much her okay I got cream wait a
minute
yeah this keeps my hands hydrated you
guys believe in hydrating no you just
feel this part right here do they feel
like a woman times yes they feel better
than a woman's hands hey when you're
alone in the woods for four years it's
nice to have a pair of women's hands
handy sorry fellas
it just makes sense the motions in my
tent come by any time this is over I'm
gonna head out west I'm gonna get a talk
show yeah we're talking two actors and
then I tell jokes about what's going on
in the news and people laugh sometimes
most times they don't
that's all John Wilkes Booth who
performed Julius Caesar one time up in
Baltimore he's a good actor John Wilkes
Booth and I don't know much about people
but I'm a pretty good judge of character
I think he's a good man you just keep
going around talking about how much you
love John Wilkes Booth and that's gonna
work out real good for you
request permission to March or do
something sir
right hey those Yankees are a
quarter-mile away they can hear you
Bret I just want to say brother you
don't know who you're fighting you said
votes from all the water
sir I saw some of the other guys
laughing my dearest and genitals pardon
mistake the captain makes us hydrating
to lovesick the other men make fun of my
soft womanly hands war is hell love
conan odor ah forward company
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go
[Applause]
I don't know I thought you guys would go
with me
[Applause]
bring your freakin hand cream on
[Applause]
don't worry captain I got this
and there's an even happier ending to
this story for on that day both north
and south United and finally agreed on
one thing Conan O'Brien talks too much
[Applause]